no matter what so all white square needs
to do I would just take one square to
the left stop the advance of this black
a pawn yeah me too
that's uh when I have the eyes on the
prize you know actually
action center and it's all these
weaknesses and he steps forward with the
queen
yeah uh also good it looks like but
slightly more risky because Black's
apron can start Motoring
also allows a pin from Prague
okay what's Queen instead is jumping in
it looks like the black porn structure
is just going to collapse note how all
the black pawns are on dark squares
they're easy pickings for white for one
second for brag
desperation now this Pawn can be
captured it can be bypassed or even more
powerful look at that white Pawn on C7
it was forking the two black Rooks one
of them jumps out the way but when this
black Rook moves white rook's ready to
start grabbing pawns Prague is going to
resign this one's going straight to
Armageddon wow
armor finals uh Duda makes a comeback
here in the Blitz tiebre